[Música]
y
de basura sacaste esta semana
las contantes o realmente no tienes idea
si alguien me hubiera hecho a mí esta
pregunta hace un tiempo yo tampoco
hubiera sabido que responder pero puedo
responder como de esta pregunta diciendo
que hace diez meses que no necesito
sacar la basura
y ven sus rostros las reacciones
clásicas a esta afirmación
hay quienes no me creen una palabra para
ellos esto es imposible
muchos aún no entienden el porqué o el
para qué de lo que hago y para ello
suelo ser extremista y hasta rara pero
por suerte la mayoría me responde con
mucha curiosidad como haces
y para entender el porqué o el para qué
de lo que hago quisiera mostrarles una
foto que considero extrema no es raro yo
ir hoy a una playa en mar de plata y
encontrarse la así de hecho esta foto la
tomé yo misma y el vínculo que tuve
durante mucho tiempo frente a esta
problemática fue la queja
al quejarme la culpa siempre la tenía
alguien más y aparentemente yo no tenía
nada que ver con esto pero con el tiempo
me fui dando cuenta que esta es una
postura bastante conveniente cuando una
no quiere asumir responsabilidad frente
a lo que ve
así que cuando esto se hizo evidente
decidí cambiar de postura y comencé a
realizar lo que llamé limpiezas
conscientes de playa
qué consisten básicamente en ir
recogiendo todo lo que entré en mis
manos en un paseo y si me encuentro con
alguna bolsa que lamentablemente siempre
me encuentro con varias lo que entré en
al menos una de ellas
de hecho volviendo a la imagen del
inicio la imagen perdón la bolsa dentro
del círculo representa mi limpieza de
ese día
como pueden ver no es una imagen muy
alentadora pero la realidad de estas
limpiezas no es limpiar en sí sino el
ejercicio de constante toma de
conciencia en el que me voy a implicada
así descubrí al menos dos cosas primero
que esta basura en realidad no era tan
ajena como había creído
recogí en estas limpiezas el envoltorio
de chocolate que me gustaba comer la
botella de plástica del mismo champú que
ya usaba
y los empaques de los pañuelitos
descartables esos que yo descartaba cada
semana
y lo segundo que descubrí fue que no
había donde llevar esta basura yo la
sacaba de la playa me la llevaba a mi
casa la ponía junto con mis bolsas donde
terminaba de ser evidente que eran
iguales
pero qué garantía tenía yo de que esta
basura no iba a volver a la playa
y si no volvió a la playa y se la
llevaba el recolector me dejaba
tranquila saber que eso iba a terminar
en el basural municipal
yo sé que muchos marplatenses no conocen
el basural así que quise traerse los en
imágenes
este es el basural de nuestra ciudad
los argentinos generamos media tonelada
de residuos por segundo que suman un
total de 45 millones de kilos de basura
al día es tanta la basura si la
juntáramos e hiciéramos una fila de
camiones recolectores a la altura del
ecuador le daríamos un poco más de una
vuelta completa al mundo
dicho de otra manera en promedio cada
argentino genera un poco más de un kilo
de basura
entonces si lo trajéramos a lo local a
las 1000 personas que estamos reunidas
hoy entre todos generaríamos más o menos
una tonelada de basura pero por si no lo
sabías esto es sólo una milésima parte
de lo que llega al basural por día si el
basural de nuestra ciudad recibe 1200
toneladas diarias y este número llega a
triplicarse en verano
pero esta es la parte visible de un
problema más grande y complejo que es el
sistema económico al que aún estamos
apostando lamentablemente como humanidad
un sistema económico lineal de
extracción manufactura distribución
consumo y descarte y la basura en las
playas en nuestras casas y en el basural
son la parte visible de este gran
icebergs
ahora volviendo a mí como representante
de cualquiera de ustedes soy una persona
común y corriente que no tiene un puesto
de poder en una empresa o en el gobierno
qué puedo hacer yo qué puedo hacer yo
para dejar la queja y en algún punto
seguir siendo parte del problema y pasar
a la acción y comenzar a hacer parte de
la solución
y en estos casi dos años investigando
estudiando pero especialmente poniendo
en práctica me di cuenta que podemos
hacer mucho y esto es lo que quisiera
compartir con ustedes hoy
en primer lugar no al descartable de
todo tipo el villano acá no es el
material sino la idea de que algo pueda
ser descartable
luego de usarse tan solo un par de
minutos e incluso segundos así comencé a
decirle a las bolsas de todo tipo y mis
compras comenzaron a verse de esta
manera
también le dije no a la maquinita de
afeitar descartable y me conseguí una de
acero inoxidable que espero que me dure
toda la vida
también dejé los pañuelos descartables y
me pasé a los de tela como los que usa
mi abuelo y el más lindo de los cambios
que hice como mujer fue haber dejado los
tampones y las toallitas descartables
por la copita menstrual y las toallitas
reutilizables de tela que son mis
favoritas
y también
nunca salgo de casa sin lo que llamo un
kit anti descartables que traje a
propósito en una mochila chiquita para
que vean que no es mucho que no ocupa
mucho lugar y que realmente lo podemos
llevar con nosotros siempre
en primer lugar siempre tengo una bolsa
grande porque si necesito hacer alguna
compra la pasada
nunca salgo de casa sin el agua que como
pueden ver además esta botella es
reutilizada
llevo conmigo también siempre un
repasador o un trapo para evitar
servilletas
tengo unas cubiertas también
unas bolsitas más pequeñas por si
necesito comprar algo más chiquito
también son de tela y finalmente
un vasito con esto puedo evitar
cualquier vaso desechable
y así estoy prácticamente lista para
todos
y el siguiente punto que quisiera
compartir con ustedes es simplificar y
con esto me refiero especialmente a dos
cosas por un lado las rutinas de aseo de
nuestro hogar no es cierto que
necesitamos un tipo de limpiador
diferente para cada rincón y superficie
de nuestro hogar de hecho en este tiempo
descubrí que sólo con cinco cosas bien
fáciles de conseguir alcanza estas son
una esponja vegetal o lupa que puedes
conseguir en farmacias o también en
lugares especializados de artículos de
limpieza
en segundo lugar un paño o un repasador
que no necesita ser comprado puede ser
una toalla vieja o una sábana
también un pan de jabón que si lo
preferís líquido podéis diluirlo con un
poco de agua tibia luego de rayar los
y finalmente bicarbonato de sodio que
puedes conseguir a granel casi en
cualquier todo suelto dietética y
vinagre el común el de mesa que en
distintas combinaciones diluidos forman
una especie de limpiador multiuso que
podemos usar para prácticamente todas
las superficies de nuestro hogar
y en segundo lugar simplificar nuestras
propias rutinas de hacer
yo me di cuenta que no necesitaba cinco
productos distintos para lavarme el pelo
tampoco necesitaba cuatro cremas
diferentes para el cuerpo y otras tantas
para el rostro pero como esto es algo
tan personal la idea de sembrarles la
inquietud y que en este punto limpieza
del hogar y su propia higiene personal
investiguen hay un montón de información
en internet y además van a estar
ahorrando mucho dinero
el siguiente punto que quiero compartir
hoy es priorizar calidad sobre cantidad
pero antes quisiera hacer una aclaración
y está bueno antes de adquirir cualquier
cosa hacernos la pregunta si realmente
lo necesitamos y si lo necesitamos nuevo
si la respuesta es que sí entonces acá
es muy importante que aprendamos a
priorizar calidad sobre cantidad así nos
aseguramos de estar comprando cosas que
no van a durar más tiempo
y recordé o me enteré que cada vez que
hacemos una compra estamos emitiendo un
voto
estamos avalando las prácticas de las
empresas que elegimos y en algún punto
nos volvemos cómplices yo decidí
entonces que no quiero seguir siendo
cómplice de la industria de la moda
rápida o también llamada fast fashion
que es una de las más crueles y
contaminantes de hoy en día comencé a
preguntarme quién hizo mi ropa y elegir
empresas y emprendedores preferentemente
argentinos que pudieran responderme esta
pregunta con hechos demostrarme que
detrás de mi compra había un intercambio
justo sin huella de esclavitud
y este punto lo conecto con el siguiente
que es consumo local o volver a apostar
a la comunidad
yo nací perdón crecí en el seno del
neoliberalismo de los 90 y algún lugar
de mi creció creyendo que si era
importado era mejor y que lo nacional en
una
pero con el tiempo fui recordando que
soy dueña de mi dinero que me lo gané
con mi tiempo de trabajo y que yo elijo
cómo invertirlo hoy pueden reabrir las
importaciones de lo que quieran colmar
los shoppings de marcas internacionales
pero yo sigo teniendo el poder de elegir
y hoy elijo apostar por mi comunidad
elijo a luciana báez que es la chica que
hizo el poncho la diseñadora que hizo el
poncho que llegó hoy que además es
coordinadora de la asociación de moda
sostenible argentina
elijo estefanía sofía dos de las
personas detrás del emprendimiento de
cosmética natural a las que les compró
esas poquitas cosas que necesito luego
de haber simplificado tanto a mis
rutinas
además enfrascan y en basan en vidrio
que toman de regreso esterilizan y
vuelven a usar siendo este un buen
ejemplo de economía circular
elijo a las y los feriantes de la feria
verde de miramar que es la ciudad en la
que vivo ahora
donde compro verduras libres de
agrotóxicos directamente a sus
productores sin intermediarios hay
mermeladas y mieles también y compra
unas hamburguesas de legumbres que pedí
cómo puedo hablar directamente con la
persona que las hizo que me las traigan
recipientes y yo en la feria las paso a
mis propios tuppers y así evitó
nuevamente las bolsitas
y también elijo a guido y a su familia
que son los trabajadores y dueños de la
dietética todo suelto tienda natural a
la que le compro prácticamente todo lo
que necesito sin bolsita
y esto es algo muy importante que
tenemos que recordar o saber los
argentinos que es algo muy difícil de
conseguir en otros lugares del mundo que
tienen que abrirse abrirse tiendas
especializadas a granel y nosotros
tenemos una dietética casi en cada
barrio de nuestra ciudad
lo que tenemos que hacer entonces es ir
con nuestras propias bolsitas de té las
reutilizables y el siguiente punto es mi
favorito es hacernos responsables de los
residuos que aún generemos y me refiero
especialmente a dos cosas la primera es
composta
o darle la oportunidad a nuestros restos
de cocina y podas a que se transformen
en tierra fértil nuevamente sin
contaminar en el proceso esto que están
viendo es la paca digestor a silva que
es el sistema de compostaje que usamos
en casa es anaeróbico y ahí podemos
poner todos los restos de cocina
cárnicos crudos y cocidos y vegetales
crudos y cocidos
la verdad que lo único que lamento es no
haberla conocido implementado antes
pero si vos no tenés un espacio verde en
tu casa puedes tener también un haber mi
compostera o una compostera con
lombrices que es lo mismo ahí mismo en
tu cocina al lado de la heladera como yo
tengo la mía por ejemplo y si no también
podéis volver a recurrir a tu comunidad
agruparte con los vecinos familiares
amigos e ir todos juntos a la casa de
aquella persona que sí tenga un espacio
verde y poder hacer una compostera o una
paca digestor a entre todos realmente es
algo que deseo que no te pierdas de
experimentar la oportunidad de ver tu
basura convertirse nuevamente en tierra
y lo segundo es hacernos responsables
también de los reciclables lavarlos
secarlos y llevarlos a buen puerto
y si en tu ciudad aún no hay un sistema
de recolección diferenciada por eso y
por mucho más es muy importante el
siguiente y último punto
que es alzar la voz o hacer un poco de
activismo
y creo que hay que perderle el miedo a
esta palabra y descubrir cada quien su
forma de hacer activismo no necesitas
participar de todas las marchas podés
colaborar con tu firma en una petición
puedes colaborar con dinero en
organizaciones que pongan el cuerpo en
las cosas que a vos te interesan también
puedes compartir las cosas que te
importan en tus entornos en tus redes
sociales como yo porque no sabes a quién
puedes estar contagiando y motivando del
otro lado como pueden ver es mucho lo
que podemos hacer cuando recordamos el
poder y la enorme responsabilidad que
hay detrás de cada una de nuestras
decisiones de consumo
y quisiera volver a la imagen del inicio
hay estudios que nos dicen que si no
cambiamos el curso de nuestros actos
para el 2050 va haber más plástico que
peces en el mar
y hoy digo bernardini en su charla hace
un momento nos invitó a imaginar nuestro
cumpleaños número 95
y yo hice el ejercicio para esta charla
y quisiera compartir con ustedes lo que
imaginé
y nos imagino felices
orgullosas y orgullosos de haber tomado
conciencia a tiempo un futuro donde
nuestros hijos y nietos pueden disfrutar
de aire puro agua potable y playas
colmadas de caracoles y vida y no de
basura
un futuro donde dejamos de enterrar
esquivar esconder y quemar el problema
de la basura porque simplemente dejamos
de tenerlo
como porque transformamos nuestros
sistemas económicos lineales por
sistemas económicos circulares donde
prácticamente todo se aprovecha y casi
nada se desperdicia
y podría seguir porque quien me conoce
sabe que no me cuesta nada soñar pero la
realidad es que estos no son sueños
utópicos y descabellados estos son
cambios profundos y complejos que mucha
gente alrededor del mundo ya está
llevando adelante
así que hoy quisiera pedirte que te
sumes que tomes cualquiera de las
alternativas que te digo y que desde hoy
la pongas en práctica y si ya te sumaste
a alguno de estos cambios o cualquiera
de los que yo hoy no mencioné que te
animes a seguir ampliando tu zona de
confort y que te animes a más
no está sola no estás solo estamos
juntas y juntos en esto juntos estamos
construyendo un presente que tiene
futuro muchas gracias
[Música]